marco
now you say polo
[Music]
i don't like to talk about this but many
years ago i myself overcame
an addiction i could not get enough of
the ponies
go razzmatazz go razzmatazz
go razzmatez
i lost everything stevie and i were beat
cops together we called ourselves
the beatsie boys and yeah it was as cool
as it sounds
see i would just stand around like that
all the time totally get it my first
partner was also pretty cool
everyone called us chucky and the coot
i got some money with my money you know
i never smoked
but i did once have an addiction food
it got bad you're not closed
it's six o'clock i need my moose you
park
i need my mature
we were doomed the minute she slithered
into the precinct
it's funny when we first met we had some
good times
looks like we both want that stapler
seems that way based on what happened
a diceki a few years back i had a minor
addiction specifically involving
the ponies i'd like to bet twenty
thousand dollars
on yabba dabba
doo i had the same exact one when i was
a kid
mom charles is hogging my dollhouse
grandma bought it for the both of us
you want some helping men no i could do
this
in 1981 he caught the disco strangler
it's over disco man put down the yo-yo
and back away from the girl
madeline
[Music]
would you care for a drink i'd love one
i'm sure you can tell i'm quite drunk
i've had a couple to build up the nerve
i think we both
know what i'm about to say raymond
i don't think we need to say anything
i'm gay that's what i was going to tell
you
well then she sabotaged my career
because i refused to
bed her i was really excited about my
first day at the 6'5
but the guys in the squad were a bunch
of jerks hi i'm terry
which desk is mine solve a case then you
get a desk
they were like that about a lot of stuff
well solve a case
then you get coffee
solve a case then you can sign debbie's
birthday card
[Music]
sounds like you needed to solve a case
exactly so i picked the biggest one i
could find
a string of b and e's all with the same
mo
guy climbed in through high-rise windows
after a month i found my suspect
dimitri kuzco an ex-acrobat with a
criminal record
circus trash it has to be him that's
exactly what i said
circus trash it has to be him i tracked
down my acrobat
got swat to surround his building there
was no way
anything could go wrong down get on the
ground
my god had a terrible trapeze ball two
years prior
snapped his spine in half so why the
kitten well
in the moment i may have gotten a little
flustered
look he's got a cat he trained a cat to
do the robberies
that's why they call them cat burgers
why is no one saying anything
yeah it's true i lost the ability to
procreate after the accident
yeah i still don't know why you dove in
crotch first i was also a model train
enthusiast as a child
those miniature tracks provided me with
some of my happiest memories
all aboard the train will be departing
in 45 minutes
[Music]
peralta can i confess something to you
i didn't throw frederick stuck in the
garbage yes i know sir
i didn't throw the duck in the garbage i
threw it off a bridge
what did the officiants say when you got
married not much
when gay marriage was legalized we
weren't sure if or when it was going to
be struck down so
speed was of the essence do you kevin
yes and do you yes yes we do we're
married
i remarked afterwards that i wish the
officiant had been more
efficient it was very funny look sarge i
think everyone knows that i
planted the idea in jake's head eight
years ago
oh hi i'm starting today detective
santiago oh
detective peralta welcome aboard i'm
hearing wedding bells
hi detective boyle it actually really
slowed things down it took like four
years for me to forget that memory yeah
my own worst enemy
you